the story of the path to coldness in
love is well known we start off full of
affection for one another and then with
time feelings fade we start prioritizing
work we check our phones while they're
speaking we don't especially want to
hear how their day went there's a
popular surface explanation for this
kind of emotional frost that people
naturally get bored of one another in
the same way as they get bored with
everything else the gadget that once
seemed so amazing the film they used to
love going cold is in this story simply
the unavoidable consequence of
familiarity but there's another
explanation dark at first but in the end
more hopeful the loss of interest isn't
either natural or inevitable the boredom
is something at once more complicated
and more active it exists because we
feel hurt by angry with or scared of our
partner and because we haven't found a
cathartic way to tell ourselves or them
about it
tuning out isn't inevitable it's a
symptom of disavowed emotional distress
it's a way of coping
we're internally numbed not just a touch
bored this can sound strange after all
we might have no active sense that our
partner has been hurting angering or
frightening us the idea appears
laughable or extreme it makes our
partners sound like monsters or
ourselves like weaklings neither of
which is true but the self that loves
within a relationship is not the normal
adult self we know from other zones of
our lives we may mostly be hugely
resourceful and resilient but the person
who loves is an infinitely more
vulnerable being we should imagine it
like a smaller younger more defenseless
version of ourselves that lives in our
heads and is no tougher and not much
wiser than we were as babies which is
when so many of our needs for and ideas
about love were formed it's this
vulnerable self that continues to direct
our hearts even if with six for two with
a pointy beard the loving self has a
gossamer thin ego
it gets hurt frightened and upset with
desperate ease you could deeply distress
it by interrupting it during a story
it's telling you about the sandwich it
had for lunch by not asking it enough
about the little spot it got on its arm
yesterday by preferring a book to
cuddling or being a bit tricky about
what channel it should watch on TV of
course these are by ordinary adult
standards tiny slights but we don't love
by adult standards these small arrows
are enough to wound the self that loves
to its tender emotional core ideally of
course the small self would at once
point out what's happened it would
carefully explain that it had been
frustrated and hurt its voice would be
measured under ffensive and charming but
mostly it just stays silent that's
forgivable it doesn't properly
understand what's wrong it just knows
it's in pain and is driven by an
instinct to withdraw and protect itself
which translates into behavior that
looks pretty cold if the adult self had
to give voice to the loving selves upset
it could sound and feel absurd which is
partly why it doesn't there can be
something especially humiliating and
having to say I don't feel you took
enough interest in the details of my
lunch break or I'm 45 years old
but not capable of sharing a TV remote
control these truly are small issues for
an adult to dwell on but the parts of us
that make themselves vulnerable in love
don't obey the ordinary adult rules the
consequence is that the loving self
dries up it doesn't want to have sex it
gets sarcastic and irritable but it
doesn't even know why it's like this it
isn't putting on an act it's confused to
learn to cope
we need a prominent mutual awareness and
forgiveness of this dynamic of
sensitivity and distress and a
commitment are decoded when
disengagement and indifference descend
we have to create a forum in which
so-called minor love sapping hurts can
safely be aired without the other
dismissing as they always so easily can
the issues at stake as childish or
imagined the touchiness of the loving
self
is ridiculous if judged by the more
robust standards of the rest of life but
this is not the rest of life when we've
gone cold
we may not truly have lost interest in
our partners we might just need an
opportunity to imagine that we are
quietly really rather hurt and furious
with them and we should have access to a
safe forum in which our tender but
critical feelings can be aired purged
and understood without risk of
humiliation
you